what do you think of our outfits yeah
we're going dancing yeah we're going
dancing I know that's the idea
superstar we're gonna go find people
that want to dance randomly in the
streets and we're just gonna dance with
them like that's the idea
you want to dance no oh are you sure
come on oh just like a little bit come
on No
[Music]
oh hey I didn't see you there how's it
going my name is markiplier I'm a you
know a hip young groovy guy and I enjoy
a little bit of dancing it's all in the
shoulders just get a lot of shoulder
action going on and they'll be swooning
I don't know who or what will be
swooning but they will oh hey you come
here often
oh hey leave this DJ elective that's
rude alright so I'm out of breath um I
don't know if you're like me but I don't
like clubs I hate it and this game is
called disco discomfort so it's supposed
to simulate the awkward feeling of being
the only person not welcome at a club so
we're gonna go into VAR disco bar and
have a hip groovy time and it's really
bizarre because those those plants or
whatever oh oh oh hey okay how did I get
here so yeah I don't know if there's
gonna be exactly like all of my previous
experiences Oh see I told you it's all
in the shoulders no hips no legs all the
shoulders try to be as clearly as
possible hey I'm here
[Music]
oh hey huh how's it going uh I like the
lady in the back just like slowly waving
like goodbye if you could just leave and
be great oh boy okay sir fine okay oh so
that's how it's gonna be okay so hey Oh
party's here baby I'm not gonna leave
this time you're all just gonna stare at
me
a 1 1 in the corner the lady in the
bikini is still dancing her pants off so
that's pretty good
oh hi ru well you're having a good time
you don't seem to move
Oh oh boy Oh God
just the staring eyes hey how's it going
you're gonna flip all the way around no
you're okay
Oh about no neck over here hey are you
having oh uh well Oh God
there's so many of you oh there's a
downstairs oh hello ladies what are you
doing what what what Huh What Huh What
What Huh What huh you want some us Huh
What huh you would what ha ha yeah
that's why I thought I'll back off okay
hello would you would you okay hello
evening officer not milady you look like
you could use some company
oof how are you standing on the edge of
that seat like that you're you you have
strong ankles but maybe just a little
too much blush hey hey how's it coming
right did anyone ever tell you that your
nose is a little lopsided
uh and also your eyelashes seem to just
be pieces of plastic stuck to your
eyelids no one took okay all right well
how about you ma'am oh that's a soldiery
look okay oh sorry uh lady are you gonna
what huh what what huh what oh what Oh
huh huh you know me to check up your
nose ha ha no I'm not gonna look down
your shirt huh your cleavage doesn't
impress me alright fine then okay but
all holy that
legitimately scared me am I am i
interrupting something
oh you're telling me what I need to do
Oh Oh mwah mwah okay all right then I'll
leave now hello
you okay why am I so much taller than
everybody
I like Connect oh hello hello how are
you doing huh
[Music]
I think she's casting a very slow spell
hello what what and you guys got to be
in better sync than that what what okay
all right you guys you guys make me feel
very unwelcome can I get a drink -
hopefully forget all these experiences
hello hi oh hi don't
don't mind me sir ma'am I don't know uh
you all have fun I'll be in the piano if
you need me just you know hiding I'm
gonna try to go downstairs maybe there's
some friends down there who can save me
from this Oh No
Oh God nut boobs I'm not sure what's
going on in this painting but all right
oh why is that painting flickering Oh
Saint Antony by Kuzma Armageddon the
garage knee at cave here well I'm
assuming that's some sort of the
developer excuse me can I escape to the
bathroom for just a moment whoa what was
that
the hell just happened there what the
hell I had a hand for a moment Oh what
why why why why did I suddenly decide to
Heil Hitler
Oh what why is it why is it so
bright now what what click to touch the
mirror oh oh well that's it are you so
uncomfortable and then I have to click
my reflection and die there's that what
I'm supposed to understand here I don't
think I don't think that's the entirety
of this experience here you know what
needs these fake people who needs these
digital interpretations of my childhood
for Tufton my young adult life you know
the moments when I actually went to bars
and clubs and tried to do this whole
deal I don't need them because I got you
guys so what I'm gonna do
literally right now I'm gonna go outside
and I'm gonna find you guys we're gonna
have our own dance party we're gonna
have a great old time here I go good to
get to get the boombox get the boom box
but get the boom box is it on play that
plan
like dance
was that oh yeah oh my gosh
well you're the first to show up so
congratulation no one hurt anything
I've already had wardrobe malfunctions
today I don't need any more what do you
have any questions for us no new pop hey
I have an idea
let's kick
[Music]
you put your hands in
so that you may absorb its power line
can also type up
Cooper
physically
um
it's if I come on
[Music]
the co but you get
yeah dancing with that I cut in
dance like nobody's watching
[Music]
I left Mike I left my phone in the car
I'll be right back
beautiful eyes heterochromia hey what's
that
but
[Music]
I'm having fun too
to return the kick can we turn the
camera